[Music]
in double life news submitted by
flip-flops versus slippers a man
confesses to murdering his girlfriend
and impersonating her on social media oh
my what you fine
girlfriend you mean he murdered the
girlfriend then impersonate her right so
he must be fine no you used her pics I
think yeah to catfish way to next level
okay yeah there's these days you know
it's kind of that's true that we just
put that Hello Kitty one on I was a
different person
he was not the same why did the mouth
have to be like that not like your Asian
girls with big ol lips all right so this
story is kind of [ __ ] up um this
started in Pennsylvania which is chill
that right well no that's Massachusetts
yeah okay okay
those were the pilgrims are at I wasn't
like that's very religious yeah
Pennsylvania so this man named John and
his girlfriend named Jamie John it's 39
Jamie was 33
John convinced Jamie to take a trip to
Vegas and so they were like in the
potential of them to move there right
that's the reason why they were taking
that trip and so once they got there
they drove out to the desert he
convinced her to drive out to the desert
to do like a bondage diet like bondage
themed photo shoot mm-hm so he tied her
up he zip tied her hands and feet to
this sign post in the desert very clever
and then he duct-taped her nose and
mouth for her to suffocate nice yeah
hide she died um and then he ended up
just leaving her body out in the desert
not Israel
yeah and then not until this family who
was taking a road trip they stopped by
one family member decided to leave
themselves like in the desert and that's
how
discovered her body Oh callate knee and
stuff so this so John was impersonating
Jamie for two months so he took her
phone and he's I'm into her Facebook and
she was he was making posts saying like
for example one post said I officially
hate my family they need to stay out of
my life I called the cops because I
won't jump to their wishes
that's one post oh he's masking that
suicide or whatever it's her being
missing yeah okay we're worried about
her or her bouncing oh yeah and then so
apparently it turns out oh wait so they
had been dating on and off since 2009
but there was this one moment where in
the relationship where she had shown up
to or like they were at a bar and he
ended up giving her two black eyes and
so I got I got to the we got both eyes
you know this one hand with - or is it -
hands think unnecessary information
thank you audible so the owner of the
bars chased him down the street with the
2000 still out there yeah sorry I felt
double punch right cuz at the same time
I mean I'm wondering - cuz why would
they say - two black eyes yeah he
probably used his right hand twice huh
I'm gonna give him the benefit about to
take the point and posture yeah so this
all happened three years ago and it got
to the point where the owner of the bar
chased him down the street and he didn't
come around her friends and family
because she beat her up at the bar well
they're saying that she showed up at the
bar so she like popped up on him type of
situation and like are they trying to
make it like she asked for it no no so
they're just saying that they're
painting how abusive he was yeah the
whole point here is you sit so and then
so he would like disapprove of her
friends and her family controlling right
but she loved him so that's why you know
she would like kind of go on and up and
then so they're saying that he was just
very mean to her on several occasions he
used her for money
and yeah so that was their relationship
but it turns out a year ago this fool
got married and she had no idea he got
married [ __ ] um and the wife had no idea
her name is Maureen she had no idea that
like you know he was still involved with
her and so forth dangerous once they
discovered this body in the desert
that's when because so she has a
condition that causes her skeleton like
her like her spine and stuff to like be
compressed so they once they found this
body they just looked at the missing
persons and they found that someone has
like a similar condition which is Jamie
because they still as of right now they
have not 100% confirmed that that is her
but this body does have the same tattoos
as her condition so it was probably her
and so they're saying oh so the wife
Maureen said that he had confessed to
killing her oh I killed her because I
had to why she was too fine and so she
was in disbelief and he married to this
other girl and he still had a killer
that's just weird
yeah why did you just bounce him maybe
no one else could have her whatever he
could move on some [ __ ] or maybe
like hold her and she was like I'm gonna
go tell your wife I mean but she went to
go do some freaky stuff with him no the
so they're saying that Jamie you didn't
know that about my wife
nobody knew but so she was so down for
him was like okay let's go to the desert
let's go into this little bondage thing
like whatever you know she's known him
since 2009 yeah so why would you do
ma'am cuz she's bi like he's not gonna
beat me in the desert or I mean but if
you're down to do some freaky things
like weird that's supposed to be like
they're still [ __ ] why else are you
gonna go into any type of fetish stuff
like let's go do a bondage photo shoot
that's so
Road Trip across the entire country so
then we can move to Vegas again right
they're talking about oh that's I know
you would not I wouldn't know where
they're coming in originally
Pennsylvania oh so they drove really
[ __ ] fall so they were like she
probably was all oh god that just seems
really [ __ ] up it seems like she was
like trapped to the point where she just
said yes to everything yeah John was
Jamie whoa I'm sorry wait go back to
John go back to Jamie damn
how old is Jamie looks 33 week I'm sorry
what she says she has Vader syndrome
what suppose she completely he look like
Darth Vader took advantage
he completely took advantage no wonder
why she kept coming back he has she
thought that nobody was gonna love her
and he probably used to know her that
type of stuff cuz I was in picture yeah
that but like part of her syndrome is
the fact that she has like like she's
more like child like a little bit so she
didn't understand she never understood
what was ever going on oh my god I
wasn't picturing a girl with a
disability that's why I just like still
typical you know like bondage you know
what she probably didn't even know what
it was that he was asking her to do or
maybe she just wanted to be loved yeah I
think is that and I think what a
horrible way to die
oh you're trusting that person she true
oh yeah I was in picturing like an
innocent little girl it's picturing like
some kind of like fucked-up girl like
how the [ __ ] did even me dude Maureen
MFO is look at his face that looks like
a stone-cold killer
yeah Wow you got the hairline of a
[ __ ] dress there's nothing behind his
eyes he's got my dream not never got
Count Dracula hair that [ __ ] is just oh
that's [ __ ] evil Janet you confess
and tell your wife I had to
to kill her why what she's harming the
wife her does she called cop was how did
they yeah thank God yeah oh because um
so also he was okay so that's what her
family and friends had already been
suspicious of John because of like
obviously like all the [ __ ] that was it
going on and so they started getting
suspicious because they were messaging
her on Facebook and like asking her
certain questions that she would know
but this guy was answering them
incorrectly and that's how they knew
that he was impersonating her and there
was even this text exchanged with a
friend because she noted like she just
realized like I haven't seen her in a
long time so she hits her up and this is
a conversation you want to be oh you'll
be Nikki cuz that's her name
Nikki and then I'll be Jaime okay what
color your blue okay Nikki's a friend um
okay
did I miss something did you and John
break up yeah but we're still friends
what happened apparently I was too
clingy and he couldn't take it
thinking back maybe I was and I and I
did try not to be but it's hard when I
care so much I feel you girl
it was my idea to be friends because I
didn't want us to hate each other
my family was also an issue as well when
is Sean's birthday that's an odd
question have you tried asking him maybe
try getting to know him no lol I just
saw a John Chapman in the paper with a
birthday didn't know if it was him lol
honestly I'm not sure about John's
birthday we dated but I didn't feel he
was the one and there was a lot I didn't
know about him he has a rough history I
know that he has a rough history I know
that but I never felt unsafe around him
and he was always up front about his
past why it's like so then she and
that's the horrible [ __ ] talk maybe
he's bored too that's all he's like like
when she ends up like Nikki ends up or
cuz you read her Nikki ends up
screenshotting this conversation and she
captions it with it makes me sick now
knowing this was him texting me the
whole [ __ ]
no the friend didn't know oh because
that's what she was trying to get John's
birthday because she wanted to do a
background check on him
I'll give her the brush-off yeah and
then giving all that extra info was
[ __ ] weird so I was it obviously they
were still friends which I think if we
learned anything today don't be friends
with your exes them all right mm-hmm
you never know what's gonna happen here
a nexus be impossible that's why people
go don't judge a book by it's cover and
I'm like I don't trust ugly people I
don't [ __ ] make friends with ugly
people I look at people in their eye and
if there's nothing going on behind that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that dude I'm I'm gonna be I'm
gonna just kick them off planes this
video was about six extremely good
people talking about something
[Music]
[Music]